[Music]
you know rachel you and i were talking
about real estate a little bit the other
day on the air when you were on here
last
and um
i keep digging into what's happening
with the market um there's a little bit
of a weird thing happening with the bad
economic news out on inflation and gas
prices and now interest rates continuing
to climb
and
now pretty much the announcement that we
probably are heading into
the second quarter of an economic
shrinkage called a recession
when the total goods and services the
gross domestic product shrinks two
quarters in a row that's called a
recession and so when it's put on the
news it's called a recession you're
gonna die but that's not really what it
is it's just you know it's a recession
it just means it receded that's all it
means nothing to panic over
but you add with that summertime came
and a lot of people
and i'm talking to some of you out there
right now
you like uh
take a vacation on adulthood
during the summer
like you can go do anything you want to
do stupid and you'll deal with it in the
fall and i'm not going to worry about
buying a house or selling a house and
i'm just going to go on vacation
and i'm going to spend money i don't
have and i'm not going to deal with this
stuff it's summer i'm putting my life in
neutral and i'm going to let it get a
little bit worse before i deal with it
and there's a little that
it's kind of a
i guess it's built into us as little
kids we go to school and we get off for
the summer and now people when we're
adults we think we can get off for the
summer yeah and we don't have to you
know and so
church attendance goes down
generosity goes down
gym
membership gym atten attending the gym
to work out goes down
it's not just because it's pretty
outside it's because you're freaking
laying around okay so uh
or you're home with the kids yeah well
or whatever
school and you don't have it there's
already there's this there's this mental
thing that yeah there's a check out and
i get that so that's adding to this real
estate market stuff hmm because people
aren't jumping up and down to go buy hey
because they're all frantic about buying
a house then all of a sudden they go on
vacation mentally yeah emotionally yes
and so here's the thing i want to tell
you guys right now
this is an unusual market because we're
kind of at this midpoint there's like a
tipping point thing going on it's like
it's getting ready to go
and flip
uh it's not it's not gonna flip quick
uh but we're at this moment in time and
i would say for the next six months this
is going to be true
that and you can't usually say this
is what i'm saying
right now
is a the best time to buy a house
in the next five years
right now
and here's why
okay prices are not going to go down
some of you are saying well i'm going to
wait for prices to come down you're
you're not going to get them yeah
they're not coming down yeah okay
they're going to go up slower
but they're not going to go down
they may not go up hardly at all but
they're not going to go down
and so five years from today houses are
going to be more expensive this is as
cheap as it's going to be five years in
the next five years so this is the best
price right now if you're going to buy a
house well interest rates are up buy the
house if interest rates come back down
refinance yeah but don't not buy
waiting on interest rates to come down
just refinance the mortgage if interest
rates come down this is the best time to
buy a house in the next five years and
here's what's weird
this is also the best time to sell a
house
in the next five years
why because we're still
have
semblance of the crazy white hot market
around
and it's really just vibrating it's
still really
like if you're a seller you really have
a real hot commodity right now you got a
nice house you put on the market it'll
go and it'll go for a really good price
right now
and it may not be that way six months
from now
the market may slow down enough that as
a seller you may have to sit on a house
for a while to get a good price out of
it yeah i don't think you're going to
lose money five years from now
but if you're if you got a i was talking
with a friend of mine um
last night that that had a
a really big expensive property that uh
he sold a farm he sold it and uh he said
because this was the best time
in the next five years to get rid of
that that farm he goes this i didn't
really i didn't have to sell it didn't
need to sell it but it was timing the
market that this is a great it's it's an
unusual statement when you can say this
is the best time to sell in the next
five years and this is the best time to
buy i know because it's so expensive
still yeah do you know what i mean so
but it's not going to get cheaper yeah
yeah it's not going to get cheaper yes
it's not get your you can't wait on it
to get cheaper because it's not going to
i really do believe that and what causes
right
what causes real estate to go down is
this a stupid question i'm saying
when supply
exceeds demand to go yes but in the
history of real estate
there's only one time in the last 100
years that it went down
okay ever
period so year after year and interest
rates always it's gone up except for the
rest of 1982 when the interest rates
went to 19 18 fixed the prices did not
go down now the sales came to a
screeching halt yeah people quit buying
because they couldn't afford to pay
payments on a 15 mortgage but uh i mean
we were i was selling real estate at the
time i was in my early 20s selling real
estate trying to make a living doing i
was in college selling real estate i
sold some houses
and you know 15 16 17 fixed rate market
but some of them were for cash people
had money um it was a good time to buy
at that time but the so it's not a
bubble what we all just went through the
last year of real estate or however long
that it's just been insane
it's not going to pop and everything's
going to go
down because i've heard people say it's
not a bubble that that like you know in
pockets of america because of the rush
you know to states with no income tax of
florida tennessee right that that these
those are what that's done is it
artificially drove the price up faster
so we like we saw in 2020 prices go up
32 nationwide on real estate i mean my
god insane yeah okay and this year we're
predicting seven percent
all right so we're gonna see and that's
a pretty good rate seven percent is not
a bad goal every time your house goes up
seven percent a year while you own it
for 30 years you're gonna be rich off
your house okay so
uh it's not a bad thing but what what
the the bubble
that is there is not on the actual price
itself the bubble is on the rate of
increase
that 32 percent is not that bubble is
going to burst it already has yeah yeah
yeah
down all the way down yet and so you're
what's gonna happen is the rate of
increase is different than the price
how fast they're going up
that is a bubble
that bubble is gone it's gonna burst but
they're not gonna i don't because we all
the data we have shows that there is
this extreme
shortage of housing
and new housing starts are not coming up
fast enough to offset it yeah so we're
not going to have an oversupply i just
wonder though like the houses like i
just think about even in our
neighborhood you know for what they're
going for like the a new build what it's
going for is it's insane but you think
they can still get that price it's just
emotional they will still get that price
though yeah they will
yeah they will the house that sold for
two million dollars
uh two months ago
five years from now will sell for more
than two million dollars yeah but i'm
saying can they get it a year from now a
year from now it won't be 1.8 it'll be
2.1
yeah it's not gonna go down
but it's not there may not be it may not
be as easy to sell it all that this is
the ramsey show